la pandémie de lakovic 19 continue de
mettre à l'épreuve nos sociétés et elles
constituent aussi un test pour le g20
l'adn de notre club est en effet de
forger dans l'urgence des solutions
multilatérales efficace face aux crises
en 2008 nous avons répondu à la crise
économique et financière aujourd'hui il
nous revient de riposter face à une
crise sanitaire qui menace avant tout la
vie de millions de personnes et nous
avons une responsabilité historique je
le redis il n'y aura aucune réponse
efficace face à la pandémie qui ne soit
pas une réponse globale coordonnée et
solidaire
nous avons cet après-midi échanger sur
les premiers succès de l'initiative
acta qui a mobilisé près de 10 milliards
de dollars depuis son lancement et nous
avons en effet réalisé des progrès
impressionnants vis-à-vis de notre
premier objectif qui était d'accélérer à
l'échelle globale la recherche et la
production des technologies de santé
nous pouvons raisonnablement espérer qu
avant la fin de l'année un vaccin sera
disponible ce qui est totalement inédit
mais un deuxième combat plus difficile
encore doit être menée
c'est celui de l'accès universel aux
technologies de santé contre lakovic 19
serons-nous près lorsqu'un premier
vaccin sera mis sur le marché à en
garantir l'accès à l'échelle planétaire
et à éviter à tout prix le scénario d'un
monde à deux vitesses où seuls les plus
riches pourraient se protéger du virus
et reprendre une vie normale
notre stratégie d'allocation des
premières doses de vaccin sera t-elle
construite en fonction des urgences et
des priorités sanitaires à l'échelle de
notre planète ou du seul pouvoir d'achat
des pays sera t-elle vraiment
multilatérale et collaborative dans un
cadre construit ensemble ou
répondra-t-elle à des logiques d'
influence des intérêts financiers des
égoïsmes nationaux
le moment est venu de transformer la
proche conceptuelle du bien public
mondial en une réalité concrète
le g20 rassemble 90% de l'économie
mondiale et nous avons sur nos
territoires
toutes les industries capable de
produire à l'échelle
les technologies de santé contre la
copie de 19 nous serons donc jugée aux
résultats nous connaissons les solutions
pour ce qui est du vaccin
la facilité kovacs nous permet d'acheter
des doses de vaccin pour le compte des
pays les moins avancés 4,9 milliards de
dollars américains ont été levés mais
d'autres contributions seront
nécessaires nous le savons il faut donc
continuer et je vous propose de
concevoir ensemble un mécanisme de don
d'une part des premières doses produites
par les industries ou pré réservé par
les économies avancées pour la
vaccination des publics prioritaires
dans les pays en développement les
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé seront précieuses
pour assurer une priorisation à la fois
efficace et équitable
le partage des connaissances et des
savoir-faire doite être au coeur aussi
de notre stratégie
il faut certes un site et l'innovation
industrielle mais en période d'urgence
sanitaire nous devons aussi favoriser
les partenariats industriels et la
production avec les pays en
développement
favoriser les capacités de recherche et
de production des technologies de santé
y compris en afrique constitue notre
meilleure protection face aux futures
pandémies
là aussi nous avons les outils pour
favoriser le partage de licences
volontaire par exemple le mécanisme
united' créé par la france dispose d'une
expérience inégalée qui a fait ses
preuves
il ne faut pas oublier au delà du vaccin
de la recherche que cette coopération
doit aussi s'étendre au traitement et au
système de santé primaires
notre mobilisation doit donc veiller
aussi à ce que dès que des traitements
contre le virus se stabilise il puisse
être de la même manière diffuser
partager avec les pays les plus pauvres
et les économies en développement
enfin je veux rappeler à tous que tous
les efforts que nous pourrions faire
pour mettre à disposition des doses de
vaccins dans ces pays n'auraient aucune
efficacité
si dans le même temps dans le même temps
nous ne décidons pas de stabiliser
renforcez parfois reconstruire leur
système de santé primaires et c'est
pourquoi il nous faut nous économies du
g20 également investir beaucoup plus à
travers notre aide publique de
développement dans ses systèmes de santé
primaires et dans leur reconstruction
voilà les quelques mots que je voulais
vous dire nous avons besoin d'une
mobilisation de toutes et tous et c'est
une mobilisation une fois encore pour un
des biens publics de notre planète
c'est la même mobilisation que nous
savons à l'oeuvre lorsqu'il s'agit de
nous battre pour le climat pour la
biodiversité
lancement à paris le 12 novembre dernier
du conseil d'experts de haut niveau une
seule santé est un très grand pas en
avant pour aller dans cette direction
mais fondamentalement parmi les leçons
que nous pouvons tirer du moment que
nous vivons la plus grande est sans
doute que nous partageons plus que
jamais au nord et au sud un avenir et
des défis communs et qu'il faut donc
partagé aussi des solutions
nous devons renforcer partout sur la
planète les systèmes de santé partout
partager les ressources qui sont les
nôtres partout continuer à former former
des personnels de santé pour que notre
riposte sanitaire puisse être à la
hauteur du défi
c'est aussi pourquoi la france soutient
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
mettre en place une académie mondiale de
la santé à lyon qui formera les
personnels de santé du monde entier et
c'est aussi pourquoi en matière de santé
nous partageons cet agenda multilatérale
qui est le seul pleinement efficace
voilà les quelques mots que je voulais
partager avec vous nous ne serons
efficaces que si nous ne sommes juste
nous n'arriverons à être efficace et
juste que si nous ne sommes
véritablement ensemble
je remercie la présidence saoudienne
pour ses efforts cette année j'assure
l'italie de tout mon soutien pour sa
présidence l'année prochaine et je nous
souhaite à tous d'être à la hauteur de
ce rendez vous de l'histoire et d'agir
je vous remercie